so now i have the vector equation of a
circle and i can combine that like if
you want to find points of intersection
p and q right
i've got a vector equation of a circle
here and a vector of equation of a line
here how do we normally find points of
intersection
we solve simultaneously right
what am i going to do here i've got a v
here i've got a v
here seems like the most straightforward
thing to do is
it's just a straight substitution in
there yeah so let's go ahead and do this
i'm going to
write down like it's always clear it's
good good to be clear and say what we're
doing here right
um to find points of intersection
which in this case are p and q i'm going
to solve
simultaneously am i right
substitute all right what do we have
here so
here's the equation of the vector
equation i should say of my straight
line
and then that's my v and then here comes
this offset that comes from the fact
that my circle isn't centered on the
origin it's
somewhere else right so i'm going to
write 1
negative 2 like so is that all right
it's rapidly getting more complicated
but i can actually start to simplify
some of this stuff once i finish writing
the equation right what's that equal to
again
three three cool okay um i've got a
string of vectors along here but this is
just going all the way back to like
extension 1 vectors it's even 2d right
i know this pesky landrum is flying
around but we can deal with that right
we can say for instance what do we got
here
i can say this is 2 plus
lambda minus 1. do you see me comparing
all the x components up the top there
is that all right i know it's a bit
sticky of me that i sort of expanded
this lambda in at the same time but i
reckon we can handle that
what am i going to get from my y
component one
two lambda is what i get from this
middle vector and then just watch that
sign
plus two is that okay how's that uh
that's equal to
three all right let's keep going i can
tidy this up a little bit i can collect
some like terms uh
two minus one
i know it's the end of the day you so we
can get there it's one one plus lambda
uh what am i getting for my y component
three plus two lambda thank you three
plus two lambda
when i go to the distance to that vector
it should equal three right
okay now just pause for a moment uh you
know you kind of write something down
and you go into simplifying mode and
then you get to the end of simplifying
and you have to make a choice where do i
go from here right what am i trying to
find again
in the end i'm going to find m but sort
of the way i'm getting there is via p
and q because
m is the midpoint of p and q so there's
a lambda a particular parameter that'll
give me oops
that'll give me p over there and there's
a particular lambda a different one
that'll give me
q does that make sense xiao does this
answer your question now
uh yeah does it does it matter which
one's p and which one's q
no it doesn't especially because i'm
after just the midpoint which is between
them anyway okay
so therefore i need to find out what the
appropriate lambdas are so i kind of
need to get out of this weird looking
equation
into something i can solve for lambda
okay
now the big tip here maybe you want to
write this off to the side because it's
not a
specific thing to this question it's
just useful all the time what we're
going to do
is use vector distances or vector
magnitudes right so over here if you
want to write down right
vector distances
they just come from pythagoras right if
you've got some vector say like this
and we'll call it p q right like so
and i wanted to know what the length of
that vector was
in other words this if i want to know
the magnitude of it
i just need to form the right angle
triangle that it lives in
because i can know what p and q are what
are p and q in this particular triangle
p would be the horizontal component so
it's this this bottom line here
and then cues the vertical component so
it's this guy right
now how can i use that to help me over
here
this is my horizontal component this is
my vertical component
what's this it's the hypotenuse so i've
got pythagoras coming out of this right
we can do this
where'd my black marker go uh here we go
what am i going to get let's see 1 plus
lambda squared there's my a squared
3 plus 2 lambda squared there's my
b squared and then here comes the
hypotenuse squared
you following so far okay now at this
point we have taken a question that was
decidedly unfamiliar
and we've converted over to something
much better we are on the home stretch
here
okay but just before i reckon you could
sort of go and do this on your own but
just before i let you off
just to make it easier for you right if
you solve this for lambda what would you
get
you get two values of course there
should be two values why are there two
values
two points one for p one for q right
now i can go and find those right and
then get where m is right
but do i really need to is there a
quicker way that can get me straight
to where i want to go which is m
say that again
[Music]
very good okay so just think about
what's going on here right when we solve
this this is just a quadratic in lambda
right when you find your two solutions
for lambda
your midpoint is going to be where in
relation to those two lambdas
it'll be right in the middle in other
words it'll be on the axis of symmetry
that's what we would say right
so let's go ahead and just kind of
unpack what's going on here what have i
got 1 plus
2 oops 2 lambda plus lambda squared
what's over here
9 plus 12 lambda plus
4 lambda squared equals 9 cancel cancel
what i've
got here um let's get this in a
reasonable order shall we
5 lambda squared what's my lambda term
14 lambda what's my constant just the
one
so what i've got here this quadratic
right i've got an a i've got a b i've
got a c
how do we get an axis of symmetry out of
an a of b and a c
think think
an axis of symmetry on a quadratic isn't
it going to be here go ahead john
negative b on to a parhan was mentioning
in the quadratic formula right
you've got minus b and then plus or
minus the square root of the
discriminant right
well one of them will be plus the square
root of the discriminant the one will be
minus so we don't need to worry about
that your average amount they disappear
that's what gives you minus b
on to a
did i get it yeah uh
cancel cancel that looks like so
i got a lambda lambda of what
this is the lambda of m right now
remember
lambda came from have a look right back
at the start of our question lambda came
from which equation
have a look the equation of the line
right so therefore i should take that
lambda and i should put it back
where in the equation of the line i mean
thankfully there's kind of not many
other alternatives but maybe
you're like i don't know maybe here well
you just get 3 equals 3 because that was
you know
not helpful so here actually i take it
back you will not get 3 equals 3
because this is solving for p and q
whereas we've found the midpoint of
p and q okay let's go ahead put it back
into the
original line substitute lambda
into line equation
don't say you're substituting it into v
because there's a couple of v's flying
around right
this particular v what am i going to get
here this v
equals 2 1
plus what is it
1 2. okay
now at this point there's some
arithmetic
uh i might do this longhand whilst
you're all working i'm going to turn
this first one into
fifths because i see i've got fifths
over here as well
so two is ten fifths
one is five fifths here's my first
vector
what am i getting on the right hand side
minus
have a look at the x's help me out
seven-fifths because it's just a one and
then minus
14 fifths if i've got that right
what do you think sorry i'm a bit low on
the board
so it looks to me like i get an x
component and a y component what's the x
component
have a look three over five
just before you go on does it look like
three over five
yeah even if you don't have like a
perfectly accurate diagram like i have
at least you're in the ballpark right
and then i've got a y coordinate rather
of
negative nine over five which is close
to negative two what do you think
i'm pretty happy with that thumbs up
okay